my name is Mandy Eccleston I graduated
from Hillsdale in 2012 my running career
started when I was 12 years old I first
started running when I saw my sister
compete the year before me and I really
wanted to do it as well I had a lot of
fun going to her meets and watching and
knew it was something I wanted to
continue I just wasn't sure where I
wanted to go right away
Hillsdale stood out to me a lot because
of the coaches it was bill Lumbergh and
Sarah Hinkley at the time and they were
just so welcoming and so excited about
me as an athlete that it really made me
want to come and be a part of their team
I met my husband on the team my best
friends are on the team from there and
my senior year just everything really
came together it was kind of a perfect
year in terms of running I won three
national championships that year to an
indoor 'none and outdoor and that's
something I never had even imagined you
know coming into Hillsdale I had just
thought I want to make Nationals one
time and that would be you know such a
huge goal and then to be able to win
three titles is really exciting and then
I was lucky enough after graduating I
had some eligibility left from getting
hurt
so I ran at the University of Michigan
for a year and then since then I have
been continuing running professionally
you know I would say a dream come true
but it wasn't even a dream when I was
younger because I didn't realize that
professional running was a thing or that
it could you know become an actual
career
[Music]
at Hillsdale the team was a huge part of
my life not only were those my friends
and my roommates those are just the
people who kept you accountable it's
really cool to be a part of a team
I know people talk about running as an
individual sport but it's really not
there's no way you could do everything
by yourself I'm very honored to enter
the Hillsdale Hall of Fame so I really
appreciate being recognized by Hillsdale
and that you know they appreciate what
I've been able to do for them as an
athlete it was definitely one of my
favorite things to wear that uniform and
race for those four years so I'm really
excited to be a part of it and you know
to be there I guess forever in history
as a part of that so I appreciate this a
lot
[Music]